I played an RPG the other day
which ones
yeah it wasn't fair on that one I asked
him for collapse and Applause let me
hear what you've played yeah well I
watched John's video uh super eye patch
wolf all right uh it was called like uh
the the cruelest video game whatever oh
yeah oh yeah I saw that one it was like
one minute of it and I was like pause I
want to play this I want to watch the
video because I I wanna I wanna play
this game yeah it's called fear and
hunger and it's just [__] horrible
grotesque game with disgusting things
happening in it
um and yeah it was it was definitely one
of the coolest video games I've ever
played did you beat it uh what makes it
so cool I haven't had time to watch
John's video yet sell it to me okay so
uh it's a Dungeon Crawler mixed uh RPG
uh mixed with resource management and
you're dropped into this world in like a
medieval setting it's extremely
extremely heavily inspired by berserk
yeah okay because the the plot is is
that you have to pick one of four
classes and your job and each character
is a different motivation for why they
want to find uh he's called legard but
in this for all intense purposes he's
Griffith yeah Griffith has gone into
this dungeon to seek more power and it's
your job to go and find him like one of
the character's job is to like he wants
revenge one of the characters to save
him one of the characters is just
because maybe he's like a vessel or
something and your job is to go into
this dungeon and save him uh before he
dies because there's a time limit and
when he's gonna he's gonna get killed
um the thing is uh is that this world
that you've entered is not your world
it's like it's like a different place in
in this world thing like Dark Continent
right right again the game is very
heavily inspired
there's so many anime references in this
in this game uh and again it's just one
big Omen to like berserk it's a plot and
so you enter this world and it's just
really like unsettling like there's no
music right away right you know there's
like really weird like you know in the
the shuffling sound an RPG Maker this is
kind of weirdly unsettling like think of
like IB and Mad Father yeah they're kind
of like scrolling around this this world
and then you know you immediately get
into this game and then you're walking
and everything's kind of like this blood
everywhere this body's hanging there's
also dicks everywhere
um everything is a dick right it's
really grotesque uh and you go to this
world and then you get attacked by two
wolves right away and you'll you try to
fight these wolves odds are you'll die
right um thing is though uh is that
enemies can attack with their limbs uh
and so wait enemies can attack so so
normally in RPG enemies right if there
are two wolves then that's two turns by
the enemy right yeah one wolf one and
wolf two right in fear and hunger wolf
one has four attacks no no it would have
so certain enemies have certain ones so
the legs are normally for movement and
they are two arms means uh for both
walls specifically they bite but other
enemies if they have two hands they have
two hits oh [__] okay and there's a
dismemberment system where you have to
dismember the enemy to then be able to
land the headshot to kill them
um but there's a there's that balance
between you can go for headshot right
away but the the chance of hitting it
very low but if you cut their legs off
they lose balance and it's easy to land
a head shot but if the enemy has arms
they sell they can still hit you and so
you can either get rid of their arms
first and then they can tackle you which
is a very weak attack right and then go
for the legs then go for the head and
it's like this kind of like Balancing
Act where you kind of gotta decide
what's the best way to go for and these
enemies do a lot of damage and let's say
an enemy has uh like a meat cleaver well
uh you know because the walls will kill
you right away and so you you load the
game up again and you yeah you manage to
get into the castle right away and ogre
will approach you right away
and will hunt you down and he catches
you right away
and his dick is just out on the floor
um it's gross uh but what you'll learn
right away is is that this ogre when he
hits you with this hacksaw he just
dismembers you and you've permanently
lost that arm for the rest of the Run
okay and if he hits your leg you lose
the leg uh and if you lose both legs you
have to crawl for the rest of the game
um so it's it's horrible and so let's
say you you're fighting this ogre right
you managed to cut his arm off he he
then at one point during this fight but
this introduces you to this mechanic he
he walks up to you and it's really like
creepy he goes a prompt will appear
heads or tails
right so then you flip the coin and if
you call it correctly you dodge the
attack if you if you call that
incorrectly you just basically die
um and in in the starting one you kind
of get dismembered and then you get
dropped in a dungeon filled with blood
and you have no legs and you're crawling
around and it's [__] and so you
basically have to restart the run
because you you can't do also death as
well so yeah back to the beginning of
the game oh no no there are saves but
here's the here's the [__] up thing
about the saves is that the Saves The
Coin tosses and if you if you if you
want if you fail the coin toss uh a
really Opie enemy will spawn to greet
you and your save doesn't count and you
have to fight the enemy and that enemy
can one shot
and if you if your party member dies
they're dead you can't revive them
and you can collect party members but
they also can get infected and they get
dismembered uh and again it's a resource
management so you're hungry right and
you have uh like MP and MP is hard to
refill uh it's called mind and they go
insane if you don't have enough of it
hunger there's not enough resources in
the game as well so you have to manage
if you want a full party which is great
because you're more powerful but you
need more food uh and so that's a that's
problematic oh yeah also there is
absolutely no merit to fighting enemies
because you don't get experience yeah
you don't they don't drop items so you
don't need to fight enemies but certain
times you'll just be you can't run away
yeah sometimes it's just quicker to try
and kill them
um and all of the items in the world are
randomly placed so it's just like a pool
so in some runs you could just not get
anything op in other runs you might get
super op items right away
um or my run uh the item to refill your
Mana uh is alcohol and opium
it's called it's called Mind Right your
sanity right so the only way to to
refill your sound is to drink alcohol or
smoke Opium get high or get drunk and I
kept getting opium but I needed a pipe
to smoke it I didn't get it right until
the end so I I was like struggling the
entire game just carrying around the
bags so what do I do with this like you
get like kids and stuff and you have to
make the kids smoke the crack or the
Opium to like help them this this sound
this sounds like a fever dream here it's
like a jlpg on crack and then like you
know it's like it's really like you know
in the start it's more like they're like
more humanoids and the deeper you go
into this dungeon and find more about
the world yeah they all start to get a
little more like really surreal and like
creepy and very kind of like uh what's
the some of the enemies just are
absolutely [__] nightmares yeah like
more nightmare fuels are very difficult
and very unforgiving and there's like 15
endings uh all you can do a bunch of
different things I got two endings both
were kind of meh it's really hard to get
the true end uh yeah maybe it's because
I'm not a gamer but this doesn't sound
fun okay so rewind to about 15 minutes
ago when you were like I'm a gamer so
like it's it's actually an amazing game
um okay and the story is really
fascinating because it's about like uh
so you're trying to save this guy but
it's about like how uh this like one of
the characters is like his village was
attacked by like the main characters
like country and Army and there's
different gods involved and there's a
whole lot of stuff going on and you pick
up books throughout by the way the only
way to get law a lot of the time is from
a coin flip so sometimes you go to a
bookshelf and to get more law you have
to win the coin flip and if you don't
you just don't get the laws
um but again like the entire game and
like a lot of reviews say this like
the difficulty does not come from uh
like any kind of gameplay it's all like
no the difficulty comes from just
knowing what to do because like as well
in the game right you just you you have
a coin flip right yeah you're like great
this is awesome I 50 50 chance for
everything that is not awesome that is
the opposite of course the game doesn't
tell you at any point uh unless you
click on the item which you would never
do is that you can pick up stuff called
lucky coins and they're very rare but
when you do get them you hold shift down
the game doesn't tell you any of this
you hold shift and then you flip two
coins
and then now only one of them needs to
land honest so you've made it from 50 to
75 chance so now suddenly saving becomes
at least a little bit safer 75 oh oh no
yeah and then like you know you're also
like walking around and there's like
prompts at the bottom of the screen
sometimes it'll just tell you
information like oh your party member's
hungry is yeah it's going low and
sometimes there's like a prompt and you
have no idea what this this prompt means
and initially it goes a terrifying
presence has entered the room uh and
you're like what what does that mean and
throughout the game there's just this
like think of like Pyramid Head yeah
like Silent Hill just following you and
he's op as [__] and he's just hunting
you down so there's also this added
pressure of that already on along with
resource management and just trying to
survive it just after watching John's
video I was like I think I would love
this game but it just sounds way too
[__] stressful for me right now it's
stressful but I think think it's a good
kind of stress where you feel very
rewarded the moment you find stuff out
right like I in this world as well like
there's this item that I wasted because
I didn't know what it was because it's
not explained to you nothing is
explained to you in this game yeah if I
didn't have twitch chair I think I just
would not have played this game because
it's just like I don't understand how
you would learn anything without looking
up a guide yeah you can't play this game
without a guide I'm pretty sure I just
don't know how you oh a little not
without like a ton of trial and errors
yeah you have to do like but even like
for this example right how would you
learn this and like maybe it's hidden in
one of the books that you've just coin
flip for you've got a thing called an
empty scroll and I opened it up and I
couldn't close it I didn't know what it
was and you just type stuff in and I was
like well I can't do anything and you
you'd put three verses in I was like
what the [__] so I wasted it and then
right at the end I picked up another one
and someone in my chat told me oh by the
way you can just ask God for anything
I was like what okay you just ask for
anything yeah I'm like are you kidding
me and I'm like how what's God
so in the game the the theme of God
plays a very like uh becoming God or uh
the existing Gods play a very very heavy
role in this and you start to learn more
about the gods okay and so you you can
just ask the God for something but you
have to type in like a very specific set
of words initially before you can ask
for what you want and I'm just thinking
who the [__] would find this out but
then you know I I did it and I I someone
in chat told me asked for this thing and
asked for it and by the way to the
there's there's healing items in the
game and your characters have 100 HP and
you only get healing items every now and
then and they're only here for like 10.
so you can barely ever heal your party
to fall yeah get found me this thing
where you can just
heal your whole party for 30 health or
40 Health with a spell that costs MP and
you can regenerate MP pretty easily so I
was like what the [__] this makes the
game so much easier because if I didn't
get the stupid [__] spell I wouldn't
have known that yeah so it's like you
you it's very punishing but also it's
really cool kind of uh trial and error
experimenting I'd say like the best way
to play the game is to just grind a
little bit just die a bunch figure stuff
out it's very satisfying and then when
you get kind of later on just [__]
look at a guide It's so funny oh no that
from the way you describe the game
that's like a level Beyond okay this is
a hard game and if you like it's not
hard it's easy but you just need to know
what to do okay that's the thing color
like brain surgery isn't hard yeah it's
easy
it's like if I gave you a Rubik's cube
right and you were able to put it in
online and and have the algorithm walk
you through every movement yeah like I
wouldn't describe that as hard right
like following that algorithm whereas
try giving someone a Rubik's Cube for
the first time being like solve it
that's hard right yeah it's the same
challenge but when you're presented with
more information the challenge becomes
exponentially easier so it's not a it's
not a difficulty that derives from any
skill or anything like that it's not
just it just sounds like you have to be
a Madman to play through the game enough
to get the information you need oh yeah
like the amount of trial never you go
through right oh [__] yeah it's I mean
like I think I went through most of the
game without looking at anything and I
got I was able to get decently through
the game uh and it was pretty much just
when I wanted to start actually getting
the endings where I had to actually look
what to do because the endings are very
odd to get like I just went through
do killing everything that I could until
I got to an ending and it was just a
weird ending I I yeah
it sounds like this sounds like a
streamer game you know I can't stream it
there like that's the thing is that like
you could only stream it recently
because someone had made an answer like
a censored mod right because it's like
there's like there's gold there's sexual
assault in it uh really [__] up things
right yeah John's video is sensitive to
[__] yeah okay it's hard to recommend
but it's like it captures that that
really uncomfortable horror vibe that I
haven't had from a game in a very long
time that I really enjoyed so I thought
I'd recommend everyone play it because
it's not everyone sorry [__] no do not
play it yeah kids uh if you found I
found the new game for you really [__]
up games that challenge you and really
make you feel anxiety and scared then
yeah it's great I fully recommend
apparently there's a second one as well
which is even harder than the first one
I've heard well yeah I mean from what I
I haven't played it obviously but uh
from what I understand from the plot
it's um uh you'd like it's very
anime-esque very takes a lot from uh
Majora's Mask because yeah okay there's
a moon right it's evil and there's three
days and the premise of the second game
is that it's a more open world and you
have to you have to be the there's like
20 or 10 other people who come on this
train journey that crashes and then you
have to kill everyone else and be the
last person alive right damn but you
don't have to kill people and stuff and
but it sounds interesting and it's set
during I think World War II yeah I
probably that it probably wouldn't be a
game for me just because I have I don't
I have patience but that just sounds
like a bad time I liked it because I I
loved berserk a lot and it really love
jumping as well it's like yeah yeah yeah
it kind of captured that kind of really
uncomfortableness that berserk gave me I
mean because it's basically like a yeah
yeah there's direct comparisons to like
and you can you can
there's a you can [__] get guts's
armor in the game like you can go
there's a place where you can get this
armor that penetrates your body yeah
like spikes and stuff
um but like yeah that's it's cool
because it's kind of like what if
somebody who is very heavily inspired by
berserk kind of did a very [__] up I
mean it does looks pretty [__] up yeah
yeah like a different take on it for a
video game where you can really delve
into it and kind of have branching paths
it's really interesting I really enjoyed
it I thought it was cool